hey you guys welcome to another in my
flickers of fear horror movie review
series today we're going to be talking
about one which i've mentioned before on
a couple of our
past live streams because i'd been
wanting to see this for a long time
if you remember a while back i think it
was on one of our matinee shows
we had covered a 2020 movie called
possessor
which was directed by brandon cronenberg
a
son of david cronenberg obviously and
what i didn't realize when i first saw
that movie
was that uh possessor was actually
brandon cronenberg's second movie and
that he had made another one back in
2012
which was called anti-viral so i went
and uh deliberately sought that one out
because i wanted to review it for this
series and see
uh you know what his debut feature was
like so
i actually watch i believe it's on
amazon prime if you have a subscription
um i actually watched it on uk shutter
so it's on there as well if you're in
the uk or if you have a vpn and you can
watch
uh shutter in other countries then you
can watch it on there as well
so i will say from the outset this is a
fascinating movie it's a
the look of it is just so awesome it's
you can tell that a cronenberg made this
it's not exactly like a david cronenberg
film i mean it's not like
you know you could mistake one from the
other from the other
but they're definitely from the same
family tree they definitely have the
same dna
they seem to have the same obsessions
the same proclivities
in their filmmaking antiviral is very
much like an early david cronenberg
movie but with its own kind of
spin on it like more kind of gloss on it
it essentially it reminded me a little
bit
i will say from the outset too that it
reminded me a little bit it's very much
like a black mirror kind of
episode it's that kind of uh premise and
i will say too that i didn't find the
premise
terribly believable but it's almost kind
of like
it was done in a weird satirical way
although it's not
funny you know what i mean even in a
black because i feel like david
cronenberg's movies
um had a little bit of black humor to
them or just a very
dry subtle kind of humor this one not so
much
um it is very serious if there was humor
in it i didn't pick it up know that
going in like i said
if you can buy into the premise if you
can suspend your disbelief
then this is actually a really really
awesome movie it has like some awesome
visuals it's very
queasy um which i like like i said
there's a lot of body horror going on in
this very much like
early david cronenberg but with kind of
a different spin on it so what we have
is sometime in the near future or an
alternate future
perhaps their uh society has got to a
point where they are so
obsessed with celebrities
that people will pay to go
to various clinics and get infected
with minor diseases that the celebrity
has
not like you know cancer or anything
like that
but um because i think that one of the
implications or one of the things they
say in the film
is that it's actually illegal to
give people fatal diseases uh from the
celebrity so it's mostly just
minor [ __ ] like colds flus cold sores
herpes that kind of stuff
so there are a subset of people
who are so celebrity obsessed that they
want to essentially have
a disease that has infected the
celebrity so they can feel
closer to them so like i said it's not
i don't know if something like
that would ever get as widespread as it
is in the movie it's like i could see it
being a really little like
kind of weird niche fetish kind of thing
but the kind of thing where they you
know it's portrayed in the movie where
everybody knows about it um you know
that you can pay and there's also
another kind of side
thing too of meat markets who
take cells from celebrities and
essentially grow steaks from them
so you can kind of eat the flesh of
the celebrity that you want it's just
kind of kind of comes in these like
beige slabs or whatever so this is kind
of where you come from
so we're following our protagonist uh is
a guy named sid marsh and he's played by
caleb landry jones
and he works for one of these clinics
that injects people with
celebrity diseases called the lucas
clinic
now what he's been doing i guess he's
kind of one of their top
sales people because they show him you
know
at the job and like people come in and
he's trying to like you know
sell them on va you know upsell them on
various things and it's like these are
you know all the diseases that we have
that belong to this person and that
person
interestingly which i thought was like
kind of an interesting commentary was
that a lot of the celebrities that they
talk about
in particular hannah geist who is kind
of like supposedly like the most famous
woman in the world or at least in this
part of the world and she has an
exclusive contract with the lucas clinic
so only they're allowed to
sell her diseases to the public that
none of the celebrities
they never um specify what they're
famous for
which i thought was really kind of
interesting so it's almost kind of like
even though like i said the premise
isn't hugely
believable but you can say like
particularly nowadays with people that
are like instagram influencers and [ __ ]
like that
you know you know or even going back a
few years with people that were just
kind of like famous for being famous
like they didn't you know they weren't
singers or anything like that
or movie stars so it's kind of that kind
of thing they just leave it vague as to
what these people are famous for they're
just famous because they're famous
and i think there's even a line to that
effect in the movie where he just says
well everyone who's famous deserves to
be
famous because they're famous and
you know they're they're talking too
about you know the celebrity culture
you know you can decry it all you want
but it's a participatory
culture in that you know these people
wouldn't be famous if people didn't give
a [ __ ] about
them and what they were doing and made
them famous essentially
so it's kind of a little bit that it's
like i said it's a little on the nose um
you know it's not subtle like in its
messaging or anything
but you know that said it's still a
really really good movie
so sid marsh uh you know he works at
this clinic
now not only is he one of their top
sales people
he also has a little sideline business
selling some [ __ ] on the black market
now obviously anytime there's a
lucrative uh
trade like this in celebrity diseases
there's always going to be a black
market and particularly there's a lot of
black market kind of [ __ ] with
hannah geist because she um will only
let people from the lucas clinic
you know sell her diseases so you know
other people want them
you know they can get them cheaper in
the black market or whatever
so what he's taken to doing is that
he has at some point in the past has
stolen
this sort of console from his workplace
this console he uses it because i guess
when they
when they go and get the virus from the
celebrity then they put like a copy
protection on it
to keep other um clinics from taking it
but also to keep it from like if you're
infected with
herpes say from your favorite celebrity
it's like you don't want to pass it to
somebody else
so they have it kind of genetically
engineered so you don't you know so
everyone doesn't get it so it's kind of
like an exclusivity sort of
sort of thing so but he has stolen a
console so he can
essentially um break the copy protection
on the viruses
and he can sell various diseases on the
black market
and a lot of times he will transport
them
in his own body so what he ends up doing
is that there's another dude that works
at the lucas clinic and his name is
derek
and he i guess has been doing the same
thing like with the black market viruses
and everything
and he gets caught so he gets arrested
so that leads to
sid being sent to collect the latest
virus that hannah geist the most famous
woman in the world
uh has contracted now so he goes and as
he usually does he collects
uh the virus for his uh employer just
like he normally would but he also
injects himself with it so he can
smuggle it out problem being
that this particular virus is fatal so
at some point
uh hannah geist dies and he is left to
uh you know deal with the fact that he
now has a fatal
and quite horrible disease and he's kind
of trying to
get rid of it that's because and it
turns out later like i don't want to
spoil too much about it but it turns out
later that it was like
engineered he can't break the copy
protection on it it breaks his console
so he has to kind of go down into these
black market connections
to try to find parts for the console so
he can try and fix it or try to find a
cure
or something like that so now as i said
if you're really really into
early david cronenberg like really
squeaky
uh queasy like body horror kind of [ __ ]
then this is probably gonna be your jam
because it's very very much like that
um i will say that if you do not like
people being injected with needles
this is definitely not the movie for you
because there's a lot of that going on
and i mean it's usually shown in like
loving close-up uh you know there's one
scene near the end where somebody
inserts a hypodermic needle into
someone's
gums like you know kind of sticking it
out of their mouth so it's
it's real it's not super super i don't
want to say it's not gory it is gory but
it's not
super over the top with the gore but the
gore that's there is real
well done it's really like skin crawling
another thing that's really cool about
it i mean the production design
design is gorgeous this is a beautiful
looking movie like i said if you saw
possessor
that is also a beautiful looking movie
this one
he really uh does a good job job of like
contrasting
this clinic and everything is just very
sterile and very
white and even caleb landry jones the
guy that plays sid marsh
he even has like his face is just so you
know he's kind of he's a ginger so his
face is just like very
pale he's just very pale and thin and
sickly looking
you know even before he contracts this
you know fatal
disease and so just this whole thing is
just
looks very bloodless and then when you
do have like the gore and violence
happen
it's a lot more shocking because there's
just these big splashes of blood on
these like really sterile
um clinical white backgrounds
so i think that was like a really i mean
the look of this is just really really
cool
like i said conceptually i like the
concept
i just felt like the the concept wasn't
super believable but like i said it's
it's kind of in the vein of some of this
like black mirror episodes for example
and some of those weren't
hugely believable either so if you can
kind of
roll with that then i think this was
actually a really really great movie
i do kind of feel like maybe it dragged
a little bit but i don't know i didn't
maybe i don't know i've watched it a
couple times and it's like
i think i liked it better the second
time because i was paying attention more
it's almost interesting because like the
first part of it is almost like a
psychological
i don't know if i want to say that
because this isn't like a really
character based you don't get to know
uh sid's character all that much he's
not super super likable he doesn't
really talk all that much
um you know because he's engaged in some
pretty like morally ambiguous [ __ ]
um you know so he's not a good person
and like i said you don't really get
he doesn't he's not really humanized
every this is a very very
cold uh distant sort of movie so it does
kind of keep the viewer at arm's length
but in a way i kind of think that works
you know that was something that some
cronenberg movies did as well maybe um
although probably not as much as in this
case
so but the character is not really
characters aren't really all that
important
uh it's more about the concept
i guess you know what i'm saying so so
know that going into it too
but it's interesting because the first
part of it is more concerned about kind
of establishing the world establishing
you know what the characters are up to
and what this society
is like and kind of commenting on that
and then at the halfway point when sid
finds out that
uh the disease that he has uh injected
himself with is fatal
then it almost becomes kind of like a
corporate spy thriller type of thing
which like i said that was a very david
cronenberg thing as well he was very
into you know
corporate espionage and uh you know just
businessmen being the these evil like
amoral
you know that would do like pretty much
anything to make money
uh you know steal one another's ideas
and [ __ ] like that so it's very much in
that vein
uh but yeah so it almost goes into like
a conspiracy thriller a little bit like
at the halfway point
also want to give a shout out for uh
malcolm mcdowell showing up in this
uh near the end i wasn't expecting that
so that was like a pretty cool
little surprise uh he actually to he's
uh hannah geiss doctor i believe
and uh he has like some skin grafts on
his arm and it's
just very weird but like i said if
you're into body horror if you're into
you know david cronenberg's stuff then
definitely definitely check
this out i think possessor is a slightly
better movie
but you know this one was actually for a
debut feature
uh it's pretty ballsy and um even though
like i said it's not the
it's not the most believable premise
because as i said
even if you know i guess we do have the
technology to
do this or almost uh to that level it's
like i'm not sure that it would become a
widespread phenomenon although there
would be some weirdos that would do it
like hey i want herpes from
you know there's even one scene at the
beginning where he's like well if we
inject the herpes like on your mouth
like from this celebrity you'll be like
she kissed you and like people are like
oh you know what i mean so it's
i know that there would be some weirdos
that would do that because you know
it's earth and humans are weird but uh i
don't know if it would be like a
widespread phenomenon
but that said i don't know this is just
this was a really really cool flick like
i said i think possessor was slightly
better
and it explores some of the same themes
but this one is much much more
body or like much more visceral body
horror in the sense that
you know it's concerned with the
intimacy of sharing a disease with
someone
and i think brandon cronenberg even said
that that's kind of where he got the
idea from at first because like he got
this flu and he was sort of thinking
about how
strange it was that you know there was
something there from another body that
had passed to your body and it was like
you know the physicality of it kind of
fascinated him
and then he said that he saw i think it
was sarah michelle gellar
like on a late shayla i think it was
jimmy kimmel and she said something
about like oh i have a cold and if i
sneezed i would infect the whole
audience
and like a bunch of people in audience
cheered like woohoo we want sarah
keller's cold so uh that's kind of where
the the strain of the idea came from
it's like yeah there would be some
weirdos that would
deliberately infect themselves with like
colds from celebrities just so they
could feel closer to them in like some
[ __ ] up way
but uh yeah so maybe it's more
believable that i'm giving it credit for
but yeah it's uh like i said it's i
believe it's on amazon prime
in the us in the uk it's on shutter at
least it was as of this recording
so if you're into cronenberg at all if
you want to see some
you know queasy ass body horror and
needle injections and skin grafts and
all kind of crazy [ __ ] like that
then definitely definitely check it out
it's a real good one uh and that'll do
it for this flickers of fear i will see
you guys on the next one
bye